just like in your ikea kid so
uh he he's pushing we're we're stuck
okay so let's say his target it is my
chest so i i keep going he's gonna keep
getting my chest
so i'm not going he goes i'm not going
like this
i'm not doing it and he moves
i'm not gonna go like that i just heal
heals he's gonna come in i yield
a same thing here
so i start here this is our starting
point
i'm on the outside of his hand curving
he goes and i'm gonna roll to the inside
pressure is gonna come back i'm gonna
ride the pressure
now i'm inside that punch and there's no
pressure but i'm contact
don't try to grab it here go around it
one more time so that you have this
shoulder
high just put the hand here for now
and then reclose the guard
so he goes follow it
inside pressure
then come back boom
don't try to grab it here without moving
or do it the other way you're going the
wrong way
follow stick ride
trap
so i'm doing that same drill
but now my legs are doing this impact
so i'm not going to leave him here
i'm not going to go like this and leave
him whatever i can
affect i affect he punches
i affect
okay
let's do that same contact drill he goes
all right and we're gonna have it where
he's gonna do that same
trying to escape okay
so he's going to escape and i'm going to
move out this way
bring my leg up to help me in that
overhook position
so he goes to escape post
move out bring the leg up
then we're just gonna come across
okay so depending on what he does
i can bring my leg back underneath um
sometimes they go ahead and try to get
out of this
that way nope just pull yourself up
got it so he pulls this way out
and then you'll find it there change
position
bring yourself near him and his hand
near him above his back pull back up
into the turtle that's very common
this is very common um and
you can kind of get it from here but
it's not as good a percentage okay so
meaning i can do who didn't get on me
from here
so i was here i'm gonna kick these legs
back
control his waist and then all i'm gonna
do
is move him that way don't over
complicate it
okay so i'm here i'm just gonna move him
over
and he's down or he's up and i'm here
i can change hands here
then come across hold the other arm and
do this
stay there
this is just right
so make sure you're following all the
same rules
don't bring the hand on his back your
goal is to push the shoulder down
so we'll go again
we'll do one drill he goes trap
boom he's trying to get out throw him
that way
with that overhook support it with your
leg
okay if i uh it could just be that
he's trying to get out here trying to
pull out you see he's trying to pull out
so he tries to pull out and then you go
over his head
bring yourself near his body he'll be
turtle
just move it out of the way
go across hold his other arm
and we'll fall in person okay so
that means i'm not taking him down
he did something and then i do something
okay so
you can you can uh picture
your art where you're gonna go here
you see but you're gonna find your
performance
ceiling go way down so
he's already stronger than me as a young
man
don't let me get up just just hear
it's never going to happen then
let's say his arm is here and i can get
up
just be strong there
it's never going to happen
the beginner will see the art statically
and then romantically they come to
believe these things are possible
okay how i got here if you pay attention
is he goes i it doesn't matter how
strong he is because
we're both moving in the same direction
then he pushes back i'm not stopping
this i'm getting out of the way that
punch
though i never stopped it and then he's
already down
that's when i moved into place i never
used the overhook to bring him down
so now he's gonna try to get out of it
you see and what i'm going to do
is not try to do some setup
where i he's there and i try to get my
foot
around his head
so he goes to get out of it and i moved
out of his way he was going that way
and i threw him that way do you see how
i did that
okay so i'm here like this now
i'm already better off than where i was
right do you get it so uh
at this point yesterday we found
your uh this way
you remember right okay but this time
he's pulling out he's trying to just
muscle his
way out of there so
i he's gonna do it i'm letting him out
and i just catch him here do you see
i'm here i'm i'm perfectly fine here
but he's pulling out and rather than
going like this
i let him go to the next control point
right here
so i'm never forcing him
then i don't like the turtle because he
has a lot of leverage
so i just move it over
then i don't want him grabbing a weapon
or anything
and i do my technique however you want
to do this there's no rules
but there's not two arcs
so i'm never contesting with him he goes
i move out of the way of the punch back
he goes to shove i move out of the way
he goes to get out
i go to the next control point
take his balance find my menu
again just a movement drill he goes
i'm blending with him blending with him
he goes boom i'm throwing him did you
feel it
i throw him he goes i throw him
he'll feel the hour i let go of it and
come to here
and control his back i don't want him
rolling though
okay which is what he would do he's an
aikidoka
he felt that energy he would go with
that energy
so i'm going to stop him here okay so if
you're going to use the other
disarm you have to have control
maintenance
don't replace don't replace with a gap
so i'm here like this i go like this
then i move out okay and then i
if i'm going to come to the trap my body
has to come down
or my other arm has to come down because
he'll roll again
okay come back so you have to control
that roll
with either your body your hand your
other hand you have to control that rope
okay let's say he does roll
right and i just have to stay with him
and i've got out of my car
so we're going to do this to continue
the movement drill
i just take in the openings that he's
giving
boom boom i'm going to first do the lock
and i'm going to give him the opening
and i'm going to stay with him
and now i'm inside control one more time
stay with him
okay